c'est à dire les meilleurs ont gagné le
fc midtjylland de vainqueur de la coupe
d'europe des vainqueurs de coupes
et pourtant les panthères avaient bien
commencé la partie un premier but rageur
un arrêt de darly zoqbi de paula symbole
d'une équipe en pleine confiance
seulement voilà face aux danoises la
moindre erreur se paie cash
quelques balles perdues des occasions
ratées et les danoises prennent les
devants déjà quatre buts d'avancé à la
pause 13-9
c'est dommage on avait bien démarré le
match maintenant je pense qu'aujourd'hui
midtjylland des plus forts que nous
voilà et il faut savoir reconnaître leur
leur qualité et le niveau de jeu casual
aujourd'hui un match forcément dur à
l'extérieur qui plus est quand on se
heurte à un mur nommé sabine englert la
gardienne a enchaîné des arrêts de quoi
dégoûter les panthères qui n'ont
pourtant jamais lâcher ne rien regretter
aux et elles l'ont fait jusqu'au bout
score final 24 19
on n'a pas su répondre tu t'amuseras
poser après c'était pas nos objectifs
nous avons travaillé je pense que
musulmans malais était la meilleure
équipe ce soir
et voilà ça fait pas payer pour nous
malgré tout cette finale restera un
grand souvenir partagé avec les
supporters qui ont fait le déplacement
les panthères seront célébrées ce lundi
soir à la salle albert auger avant de
reprendre le championnat
un titre national à aller chercher